Transcriber: sepsa Alhaj Yousef
المدقّق: Dalia noreldeen
مرحبًا، أنا ديما.
أدرس دكتوراه في الكيمياء التحليلية،
حكم شطرنج، وعازفة غيتار.
هذه الأشياء تجعل الأشخاص دائمًا تقول لي،
ديما أنتِ شخص مجتهد،
ومثابر ولديك شغف، وحب للتعلم،
وللمعرفة وللعلم. صحيح جدًا لكن،
إذا عدت بالوقت إلى الوراء،
فديما هي شابة عجولة وانفعالية ومتسرعة،
قراراتها لحظية مبنية
على الإحساس بدون تخطيط
بدون تفكير، وبدون تحليل.
“طيري” هو اسمي
عندما كنت صغيرة،
لأن في كل مرة أركل الكرة
أصرخ بصوت عالي “طيري“.
وذات يوم، طارت الكرة،
وعلقت بعمود كهربائي، ومن هنا أتى اسمي.
كانت حياتي مليئة بالرياضة،
والسلة، والطائرة،
والتنس، والسباحة، والدراجة.
لهذا السبب، كان وقتي مليئًا
بالتدريبات، والتمرينات،
والبطولات، والسفر، والمباريات،
والربح، والفوز، والخسارة،
والتعادل، والشغف.
كنت أسمع الكثير من التعليقات،
كأي شابة تلعب رياضة بشكلٍ كبير،
كان يجعلني البعض أضحك
والبعض الآخر يجعلني أضحك كثيرًا
كانت إحدى التعليقات “أجت أُم ربحنا وخسرنا”
وكانت إحدى التعليقات، “راحت أُم البطولات”
وأكثر شيء كان يجعلني
أضحك عندما يقول لي أحد ما
“ديما حمودة من سيتزوجك
وأنت تركضين خلف الكرة”.
حسنًا، هذه الأشياء لم تكن تؤثر بي،
بالعكس تماماً، كنت أتمنى
من الذي يقول هذه التعليقات
أن يكون معي يومًا ما في أي تدريب أو تمرين
ويشعر بشعور واحد فقط
من المشاعر التي كنت أشعر بها.
استمر هذا الشيء لوقت البكالريوس.
وهو مفترق الطرق،
حيث مر جميعنا بهذه التجربة.
عندما كنت في البكالوريوس لم أستطع
التوفيق بين الدرس والرياضة.
وأنا قمت بالاختيار،
أو بالأحرى عائلتي اختارت الدرس،
وهذا الشيء الذي يجب أن يحدث.
يجب أن نختار الدرس، ولأن كان لدي فضول
لأعرف كيف تتركب المواد،
وكيفية تفاعل الذرات مع بعضها البعض
لتُشكّل مُركّبات،
لهذا السبب درست كيمياء تطبيقية.
والذي حدث أن يوم بعد يوم
بدأت الحياة تتغير وأنا بدأت أتغير.
الضحكة التي كانت على وجهي بدأت تختفي.
الحياة أقسى، والظروف أصعب،
وبدأت الحرب في البلد.
أتذكر في يوم رأس السنة عام 2014/2015
قمت بإحضار ورقة وقلم، وكتبت
“أنا اسمي ديما ولدي 8 مواد للتخرج
صعبين للغاية، ولا أملك عمل لأقوم
بتصليح غيتاري المعطل
وليس لدي أصدقاء مقربين
ووحيدة، وضعيفة، وحزينة“.
وكتبت، ما هو الحل؟ إشارة استفهام،
وتعجب، ونقطتين.
كيف يمكن للإنسان أن يبني ذاته من الصفر؟
أو إذا أردتم، تحت الصفر؟ كيف؟
وأدركت، أنني أريد أن أكون أكثر ذكاء،
فذهبت إلى صالة شطرنج،
وأن تذهب لصالة شطرنج،
وعمرك فوق العشرين، هذا شيء مستغرب،
إنها رياضة كأي رياضة أخرى.
يجب أن تبدأ بعمر الخمس أو الست
أو السبع سنين كحد أقصى،
لكن أنا ذهبت بعمر الخامس والعشرين.
وعندما ذهبت لصالة الشطرنج،
وجدت شيء آخر، رقعة الشطرنج بالنسبة لي،
كانت مساحة تعكس الحياة، كل شيء منظم
ولكن يوجد عدد لا نهائي من الاحتمالات.
كل قطعة لديها هدف، وغاية ومعنى،
وكل مربع من الأربع والستين مربع
له احداثيات وحرف ورقم
لا يوجد شيء عشوائي مثل الحياة.
الاحتمالات كثيرة.
ولكن صدقوني، لا يوجد شيء عشوائي
أول شيء أردت تعلمه في الشطرنج هو الصبر.
عندما رأيت لاعبة لكي تقوم بنقلة واحدة،
قامت بالتفكير لأكثر من عشرين دقيقة،
أكثر من عشرين دقيقة لكي تقوم بنقلة واحدة.
وأنا شخص عجول متسرع.
كنت ألعب ويداي متشابكتان وراء ظهري
كي أتعلم الصبر، والهدوء،
والتفكير استراتيجيًا.
الشي الآخر الذي علمني إياه الشطرنج،
أنه لا يوجد شيء مستحيل.
عندما رأيت بأم عيني طفل عمره خمس سنوات
كان يجلس على ثلاثة كراسي لكي يرى الرقعة.
هذا الطفل استطاع الفوز على شخص بعمر
الخمسين. لذلك لا يوجد شيء مستحيل كالحياة.
علّمني الشطرنج الحلم.
عندما أدركت أن البيدق قادر للوصول والترقية
ويستطيع أن يصبح وزير،
وبمناسبة حديثنا عن الوزير،
أود أن أقول لكم
أن اسمه ليس وزير، اسمها “Queen”، “الملكة“.
أيتها الشابات لا تسمحوا للشباب
بأن يقولوا لكم وزير، هي “Queen”
وهي أقوى قطعة من حجار الشطرنج.
علّمني الشطرنج أشياء كثيرة انعكست
على حياتي، ولكن أكثر شيء أحببته
بأن هذه اللعبة ليس لها خصم،
أنا واللاعب الرسيل،
نلعب على الرقعة كالحياة.
لا يوجد خصم.
تبدأ المباراة أو كما نطلق عليه
دور الشطرنج بسلام، وتنتهي بسلام.
الشطرنج أثر إيجابيًا في حياتي،
لأني رأيت فيه مساحة تعكس الحياة.
الشابة التي لم تكن تستطيع التخرج البارحة،
اليوم سوف تبدأ رحلة جديدة في الدكتوراه،
الشابة التي لعبت بعمر متأخر في الشطرنج،
اليوم، أصبحت حكم.
وأذكر جيدًا عندما قال لي حكم دولي،
“ورقة امتحانك بالتحكيم
محتفظ بها في أرشيف مكتبتي“.
حاليًا، أنا أحاول بكل شغف وبكل صدق،
أن أنقل هذه التجربة لكل متدرب ولكل متدربة،
أطفال، ويافعين، وشباب، وشابات
وأكثر شيء للسيدات.
أريد أن أقول، أنا وجدت شغفي وتمسّكت به.
هل أنت أو أنتِ، وجدتم شغفكم؟
ممكن أن تجدوه في أغنية تغنيها،
أو في موسيقى تعزفها، أو في رقصة ترقصيها،
ممكن أن نجد التفاصيل الصغيرة موجودة حولنا.
أريد أن أقول للجميع،
ابحثوا عن شغفكم وتمسّكوا به.
لأن النجاح هو صديق وفيّ جدًا للشغف.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)